hi there this is Liam Patton from big
star games and we're going to show you
Reservoir Dogs bloody days in these
cases as you see the top-down strategy
shooter but as we didn't want to do just
another shooter we added the time rewind
gameplay mechanic which is original on
itself where we will show you in this
jewelry heist how do you implement it
you will be playing with three different
characters at the same time but
constructing different timelines so in
this case the leader which is mr. white
I'm going to kill few cops from the
center of the screen and after I build
up some seconds I swap characters I'm
using brown and when the time runs by
I'm using our blonde to open up
different paths while Brown is stealing
white was killing cops in the center or
blonde is doing some other activities so
use very well your strategy
this game is thought not only to shoot
but also to rob also to abduct and
coordinate yourself to escape and to
fulfill the different heists that you'll
have to do in the game you see Brown
just robbed the civilian and what is
this money flow you will need money in
order to upgrade your weapons and also
unlock new heists and while I'm getting
ready for the next wave of cops gonna
show you something different here I use
white and brown was hidden behind the
column to the cop didn't shoot it but
now that Brown is moving the AI is of
the Caucasus is attacking him so the AI
is in real time and I've altered the
timeline that white grey
this means that the cops are not silly
and you need to watch out if you like
the timeline that you have created with
the leader be aware that the other
players basically also soulfully
properly or the enemies will really
really catch this case we're now
cleaning the room we are gone and one
thing I want you to pay attention to as
well is the bullets with mr. white you
show the line marked and white under the
feet of the player of the character
serene I have only one bullet left but
I'll come to this later now we're going
to show you a different time make a
gameplay mechanic with the umpire you
need to steal as much money as you can
or reach into 3000 in a given 30 seconds
time now coordinate yourself properly
while white was feeling on the upper
side of the screen now Brown is stealing
some other areas and now Blunt will come
into play you need to be smart you need
to play in a coordinated way in order to
fulfill this time trial - the more
points you get the more combos and this
since isn't a score attack game the
combo system you need to watch out will
be very very important to reach the top
of the leaderboard remember white I had
only one bullet list so the cop coming
from the left I killed him so I need to
protect myself there so I'm not making a
very long Turner
on Eugene has brown brown will protect
white from the two cops that appearing
and since the turn was short those of
five seconds only I need to use now
blonde smartly helping Brown while white
is just hidden behind those columns so I
have white use my fists I had no bullets
left and I grabbed the gun from the dead
cop so there is no ammo there is no
health you need to very very coordinate
and we be aware that what you know the
bullets that you using you not
necessarily need to be a happy trigger
guy here in this game you need to be
very very precise on how you you
on this final weight final stage of this
checkpoint
I see why getting real over to cops
don't forget he's the leader he's
building up time so I build up here
around nine seconds and Brown will come
now into action but the cultural life so
I hide behind the wall while while white
is getting rid of them and now
Brown has reach the checkpoint next
stage nearing for home from the police
pump so what am I going to do now I'm
going to start with white on the top
side of the screen and look what's
happening to brown and blonde they're
being killed but no worries they are not
killed in reality they are killed in the
timeline at the leader mark so I'm using
brown now and I hide behind the wall
and blonde is still being killed but now
I can this blonde and I save him because
white is on the top Brown is behind the
wall and blonde is helping the others
getting rid of the top in this way you
will see very important again the ammo
and the health even in this case they
were first to dead and now I have full
health with all of them going to the
next day one other very important thing
in this game is the passive skills so
what are passive skills of the dogs
those are the white is a wise guy but he
has one he intimidates crowd so he has
crowd control
so the civilians will not walk and
interfere in the trajectory of the
bullet and explain you some passive
skills later now I wanted to show you
another tool so with white I went to
steel on the Left Oh what is this - now
is fast forward so being an action game
we really want you to do many many
things and as there were many enemies I
wait white was waiting for brand to come
in I fast forward the action so you
don't need to wait now blunt will help
round getting rid of a cop and the
leader will set up again the time the
leader is white and we said that he has
this passive skill of crowd control and
blonde for example get a sadistic die so
we give you more time with blonde to
build up the combos there will be cases
for example Brown you need to steal
money back so Brown being a big and tall
and strong strong man he will not be
penalized on the on the speed while he
carries the weight of those moneybags
alright I'm building up some time here
sorry I'm using the time that white made
and I'm fast-forwarding again so to let
your I just explained so I'm using now
the time to steal more money so with lon
drop some weapons look at the ammo I'm
pretty good on health here
blondie it is only like 25% down so I'll
accelerate and I'll get ready for the
next stage everyone is work position so
white goes left
oops but I've seen a guy on the right of
the screen so let's show characters
again and I use brown strategically open
the door is bang and get rid of the of
the top there so again cooperative mode
but with yourself so now Blanc and can
get some of the money that the civilians
were carrying now you see the arrows
underneath the sign of the of the
characters showing me where to go to the
next checkpoint so I place I place white
there accelerate steer
blonde is already there and now I need
to bring brown so I have a few seconds
left time made it so I'm going to the to
the parking lot area don't forget we
just stole a jewelry so once you are
mastering time rewinding mechanic you
can go full Rambo mode and get rid of
the cops as many as you can
I saw a couple there so why when on the
left you got it has no bullets left so
Brown went to the right and got rid of
those too so blonde now we'll wait for
white and heat as many Massacre I'm
trading my mayhem here so as many as I
can quickly with white I need to grab a
gun I have the gun wait behind the car
and now blondie step so let's try and
help blonde once the turn is there
I'll move blonde out of the trajectory
so solid exactly like that and the whole
parking lot now is clean guys now that
is clean you see the white arrows
indicating the next stage we want to
thank you for watching this was one of
the one of the first heists Reservoir
Dogs bloody days will be available on
May 18 on PC and later on on console
thank you very much for watching we
really hope you enjoy the game